[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui mag
listes l'une des rares à avoir écrit des
best-sellers c'est henriette valter qui
publie les petits plats dans les grands
chez robert laffont
une histoire des mots de la cuisine et
de la table bonjour henriette walter
alors on peut se demander l'intérêt
qu'il peut y avoir à mêler la
linguistique et les cuisines et bien
c'est évident dès l'instant où l'on
apprend par exemple que le mot copains
je vais appris en lisant votre livre le
mot copains ça vient du fait que c'est
celui avec qui on partage le pain tout
simplement ci avait pas de paille avait
pas de copains comme vous dites
c'était une histoire du moyen-âge où il
n'y avait pas d' assiettes comme vous
savez bailly a pris au cela vous voilà
exactement de l'acier est telle qu'on la
connaît des arrivées qu'au 16e siècle
avec les italiens qui nous ont donné
cette habitude en fait à l'époque le ça
vient du verbe
ce soir c'est à dire c'était l'endroit
ours asseyez sur la table et donc on
disait à chacun tous attendent assiette
c'est là c'est à dire celle qui va te
mettre voilà et est alors avant avant
l'assiette gelais a pris donc en lisant
votre livre on se savait du pain le pain
c'est ce sur quoi on versait tout et
tout ce qu on allait manger c'était la
sienne s'est elle pas exactement parce
qu'en fait il n'y avait il n'y avait pas
d' assiettes
il y avait des écuelles et il y avait
des tranches soir les tranches soir sur
lequel on mettait du pain et le pain
était absorbant et il lui permet il
permettait d'absorber la sauce qui
étaient autour de la viande est alors
chaque chaque chaque convive disons
entre deux convives
il y avait cette possibilité et les
copains étaient ceux qui partageaient le
pain et quand on parle copains on parle
aussi camarades mais alors camarades
commencent à recommencer fait ça qu'est
ce que c'est que ça qu'est-ce qui
partage légal et camarades
hihi partage la chambre et là c'est une
histoire de venue de dudu d'espèces
d'espagnol si j'ose dire puisque la
chambre c'est qu'un quart mais l'un et à
caméra
l'espagne c'est la chambre voilà ça a
donné camarades comme un pas donné
compagnon mossi compagnie partage de pas
exactement c'est à dire que on a deux
formes la forme simple et la forme
compliqué si j'ose lire un dérivé dix
ans avec la dérivation sur coppa
lyonnais mais non pas sur compagne au
voilà alors quel rapport y at il entre
le sel et le salaire parce que le
salaire ça vient du sel est exactement
alors on peut se poser la question et
c'est à dire mais que vient faire le
salaire en a dedans et bien dans
salaires il y a le seul avec sa l'on
repère bien le latin salle mais il faut
savoir que du temps des romains pour le
pour le lérot recomptant récompensés de
leur travail
on leur donnait une petite partie de
celles c'était la quantité de sel qui
étaient quittes former leurs salaires
c'est-à-dire leur rémunération
alors il faut comprendre l'intérêt du
sel pendant des siècles c'est ce qui a
permis de conserver les aliments avant
l'invention du réfrigérateur
heureusement qu'on appelle celle sinon
on serait souvent morts de faim d'où
l'importance du sel à l'époque si on
donne du sel aux soldats romains c'est
parce qu'ils ont ils en ont usage
exactement et puis c'était très cher ça
ça coûtait très cher donc c'était
quelque chose de très valable c'était
c'était quand on avait du seul on était
on était riche et d'ailleurs on comprend
à ce moment là pourquoi il ya tellement
de beaux en français avec celle on a
salaisons on a comme vous dites il ya il
y a le salaire mais il y a il y en a il
ya le la sauce il y a le sauffisseau la
sauce liste et le saucisson et que ça
nous permet de dire quoi là du point de
vue linguistique parce que bon quand
vous avez compris ce livre c'est ce
n'est qu'une occasion pour moi de parler
de ce que je sais et non pas de la
cuisine que je ne sais pas aussi bien
qu'il le faudrait mais mais de ce que je
sais c'est à dire la langue et les ce
qui m'intéresse dans non dans la vie
disons est bien là là quand je vous
parle de la saucisse et du saucisson
on se rend compte que la saucisse
elle est petite elle est fine et le
saucisson et gros car il y à un suffixe
là qui est ont quitté aussi suffixe qui
viennent de l'italien qui c'est qui
signifie qui dit tout le temps que ça
veut dire que c'est gros mais il faut
faire attention parce que en français on
n'est pas toujours augmente hâtif il
peut être dix minutes et en effet quand
quand vous prenez par exemple vous êtes
sur une table vous vous dites le sale
rond le sale rond c'est une petite salle
r c'est pas une grosse saliens drôle en
l'utilisant tenue tellement mais on
utilise souvent le manque ou lyon par
exemple
bien sûr bien sûr mais même si vous
prenez le carafon le car au fond c
politique taha voilà mais le 106 ans et
plus gros et attendez attendez il ya
mieux il ya la rillette et le rayon la
rillette fait plus ico lorient le rayon
et plus gros col à la diète et ça nous
permet de travailler un petit peu aussi
sur les diminutifs donc là on a vu le
menu les augmente hâtif mais on a aussi
les deals est le diminutif diminutif est
alors là quand je me suis trop j'ai
commencé à travailler là dessus monsieur
posé la question mais se dit dans la
langue française est dans la cuisine
quel est le suffixe le plus fréquent et
je suis tombé sur est justement
alors voilà bien sûr tout à l'heure on a
parlé de rillettes
mais vous allez on trouvait bien bien
d'autres avec moi la croquette la lada
pardon la crépinette la pop young
exactement alors la pop il est elle est
amusante aussi on a parlé tout à l'heure
du suffixe italien aux dés et bientôt
paupiettes servira aussi de l'italien
polpette à la pommette et la petite
voulait alors continent il ya c'est les
salaires on l'a vu on le remarque tout
de suite quelque chose qu'on remarque -
c'est le rapport qui peut y avoir entre
eux les épices et les espèces des
espèces au sens de l'argent aujourd'hui
on utilise le mot espèces pour parler de
la mort
mais en métal et des billets quel
rapport entre épicé et c'est le même mot
latin mais et pis c'était à l'époque
lorsqu'on voulait récompenser une
personne qui vous aveugle qui toutes
avaient rendu service surtout pour comme
quand on est on allé au tribunal qu on
avait quelques difficultés
on lui importait des épices alors qu'ils
étaient tout aussi précieux que celle
même de dos espèces plus tard voilà
qu'est ce que pourquoi les épices
était-elle si si précieuse on sait qu'on
a fait des guerres pour les épices on a
on a le l'essentiel du commerce avec la
chine avec l'amérique c'était les épices
qu'est-ce qui était pourquoi c'est si
important pour nous les épices vous
l'avez dit en fait c'était très ça
venait de loin donc ça coûtait très cher
et les épices ont été alors les épices
ont été aussi quelque chose pour
améliorer la nourriture pour lui donner
un peu plus debout donc donc c'était un
petit peu un luxe de mettre des épices
la plupart des épices étaient très
chères elles venaient de très loin mais
on pouvait aussi avoir des épices un
petit peu moins cher on pouvait
retrouver dans le pays
au lieu de prendre les choses qu'ils
venaient de loin et je pense je pense
que vous avez remarqué tout s'est tu
c'est ce petit travail que je me suis
amusé à faire pour essayer de voir
quelles cases et et quel était le pis le
piment le plus le poivre le plus piquant
du public ans au moins au moins piquant
vous savez on a le paprika on a le le
pili pili on a le poivre de cayenne et
sait on à larissa on a là voilà alors
chacun venant d'un certain dans certains
pays mais chacun étant un petit peu plus
fort que l'autre
voilà donc ce travail enfin en rien
valter si on utilise beaucoup moins des
pistes aujourd'hui qu'on utilisait jadis
c'est parce que la nourriture est
meilleure les produits est en meilleur
on a moins besoin de maîtres de l'est
des épices alors qu'autrefois au
moyen-âge pour toutes les raisons qu'on
imagine
on s'est moins bien tout à fait tout à
fait vrai aujourd'hui on a les
réfrigérateurs on a les congélateurs
mais quand même quand vous travaillez
quand vous essayez de voir ce que sont
les grands chefs les grands cuisiniers
actuelle il utilise des épices mais dix
utilise avec beaucoup de modération avec
beaucoup de soin ils sont là en se
disant attention cette épice là il
faudrait pas le mettre avec sept autres
épices parce que ça pourrait déranger ça
pourrait il faut il faut retrouver le
goût de de la matière première
disons voilà est d'être un tout petit
peu des pistes juste pour améliorer la
chose simplement
alors parmi ceux qui vient de loin il ya
un animal qui vient de loin c'est la
dinde la dame elle vient d'inde
on l'entend dans le monde c'était la
poule e d'inde
mais alors ce qui est très drôle quand
on voit cet animal c'est que nous on
appelle ça une dinde les anglais
appellent ça une turquie türk et et les
portugais appelle ça une paire ou le
pérou est le rapport entre les trois
elle vient d'où la dame alors justement
alors on commence par le par nos par nos
dos était on disait la pole tendre ça on
a commencé par dire la poule d
apostrophes yên des oeufs d'or et
ensuite on a dit d'inde des add yên 2e
en a enlevé l'apostrophent ça c'est une
chose maintenant qu'est ce que c'est que
c'est un dollar est-ce que c'est lundi
que nous connaissons c'est à dire le
quai quitte en asie où est-ce que c'est
autre chose d'assez bien d'autres choses
bien sûr il s'agit de 2,2 de la belle
petite erreur qu'avec christophe coulon
quand il est arrivé en amérique et qu'
il a utilisé cherchait la route des
indes à prédire et donc on a commencé
par rappeler cette région cette fin de
cette île sur laquelle il est il est
arrivé là au début on l'a appelé l'inde
et les français
on a appelé ça les indes occidentales
pour les distinguer des indes de l'un
d'eux tel que nous le connaissons
aujourd'hui donc indes occidentales
et on le retrouve en anglais en anglais
ou pour dire les antilles on dit parents
pille on dit ouest
nds c'est à dire les indes de l'est de
l'ouest
mais alors pourquoi les anglais
appelle-t-il la dinde la turquie c'était
s'est passé par la turquie si j'ose dire
c'est à dire qu'ils étaient des voyages
ou leurs cours et on s'arrêtait plus
voir dans les escales que l'on pouvait
et autres là s'est arrêtée là pour les
les portugaises c'est le pérou mais il
faut savoir que turc et en anglais
autrefois ne désignez pas là la donne
mais désigne l la pintade
donc voilà on en perd son latin pourquoi
ces connaissances de géographie plutôt
plus de pros c'est la balle qui résiste
pas au plaisir de se montrer voilà une
oreillette
l'étymologie de foie gras alors ça c'est
très amusant
une fois gras ne date pas d'hier 1 et
alors qu'est ce que vous entendez vous
linguiste dans foie gras voilà alors
dopé le foie dans fois moi j'entends
j'entends les figues
alors on se dit mais qu'est ce que vient
faire que vient de faire les figues dans
le foie gras dans le foie tout tout
court et bien en latin on disait fica
tome i et courent c'est ayez cours qui
voulait dire fois et fica tôt c'était le
foie aux figues ou les fois le foie des
oies gavées aux figues et cela on le
sait on le sait par un grand gastronomes
et cuisiniers du latin qui s'appelait
apicius et qui a fait un livre j'ai ce
livre d'ailleurs et j'ai essayé de faire
certaines recettes qu'il donne dans ce
livre est il le raconte
il raconte que au nom pour faire un bon
un bon foie gras il fallait un beau
foire disons parce qu'en fait nous nous
appelons ça le foie gras mais en fait il
est toujours grand puisque on le nourrit
de figues afin que afin qu'ils fassent
la dass voilà
et qu'est ce qu'un qu'est-ce qu'a
légumes pour vous plaire alors oui alors
on se pose la question aujourd'hui un
légume c'est quelque chose qui
accompagne la nourriture qu'ils compagne
la viande quiconque qui accompagne le le
poids le poisson etc
à l'origine les légumes ne désignait que
des des matières premières disons
j'allais dire des légumes des matières
premières qui étaient dont les graines
étaient dans des gousses donc le
lancement voilà comme comme les petits
pois voiliers ou encore le petit pois
les fèves pois les faits et les antilles
et c'est donc à l'origine c'est ça alors
aujourd'hui on a un petit problème parce
que comme le turdu c'est quelque chose
qui accompagne quelque chose de sale et
mais en fait un légume ça pourrait être
autre chose on pourrait très bien faire
je ne sais pas s'il ya des cuisines et
qu'il faut on pourrait très bien faire
des petits pois avec une sauce sucrée
pourquoi pas certains le font d'ailleurs
effectivement et est un fruit pour vous
c'est quoi un fruit alors oui alors
justement la différence entre légumes
frais et fruits est un petit peu
délicate à fait si on prend l'ancien sun
l'ancien sens qui était ce qui fait
plaisir ce qui fructifie vous voyez
comme comme quand tu te dis oh quand on
dit le fruit de votre travail
voyez c'est ce qui bénéficie ce que ce
qui est bon ça fait simplement c'était
très abstrait c'était pas du tout le
fruit tels que pour le connaît
aujourd'hui
ça arrive le sens a évolué et on se rend
compte et ainsi quand on commence à
travailler là dessus que dans les mots
de la cuisine se produisent les
exactement les mêmes évolutions que dans
les mots de tous les jours de tout de
tout autre chose avec évolution avec un
sens qui change avec un sens qui se perd
ou avec des mots qui disparaissent et
d'autres qui reviennent ou qui sont
inventés à la tomate
on se pose depuis la nuit des temps j'ai
l'impression la question de savoir si
c'est un fruit ou un légume exactement
parce que en fait comment on le prend en
hors d'oeuvre
on ne prend pas souvent en dessert donc
rose ça devrait être un fruit puisque
c'est par un légume puisque c'est pas
c'est ce ne sont pas des graines dans à
l'intérieur d'une d'une gauche n'est ce
pas comme ça devrait être un fruit mais
comme on le sert très souvent en hors
d'oeuvre en salades etc
on a l'impression que que c'est plutôt
un légume puisque ça accompagne nos
repas reprend en entier oui c'est ici on
alors d'où ça vient tomates d'où ça
vient ça vient d'une langue 13 ans très
très lointaine puisque ça vient d'une
langue du mexique qui était le nahuatl
je sais pas si vous entendez ce que je
dis depuis longtemps à peine mais c'est
très difficile à entendre
mais en face à mayence et et autres là
c'est une consonne que les espagnols
n'ont pas n'ont pas su répéter quand ils
sont arrivés en europe
quand la tomate est arrivé en europe
c'est pourquoi on dit tomates et en
espagnol et non pas tomates
les voilà voilà donc voilà c'est ses 7,7
peuplades indiennes qui nous est donné
énormément de fruits et légumes parce
que je crois que dans votre livre le
monal revient très régulièrement
exactement et les les nawak la langue
existe encore au mexique
et voilà vous savez qu'il ya aussi le
chocolat c'est la même chose mais comme
sahin afin que les espagnols n'ont pas
su attendre et qui ne nous ont pas donné
on s'est mal prononcé cette personne
mais en fait quand on fait de la
politique ça nous amuse beaucoup de
français à 7 à 7 personnes bizarres qui
qui commence par un thé et qui semble de
terminer par elle
voyez c'est ça la sacem ça c'est le
plaisir des phonéticiens vous savez les
freins et live live c'est quoi ça vient
d'où cycle justement là il s'est à
nouveau un lieu et qui a alors vous avez
la gousse d'ail la tête d'ail et la
gousse d'ail
alors la tête c'est ça qu'on prend
beaucoup de mousse et voila voila c est
ça nous
cette chose à mes très souvent on met
lie avec l'oignon alors l'oignon c'est
plus intéressant que l'ail du point de
vue étymologique vous voyez parce que
abobo style à lui ou latin bon d'accord
au vert et après et après mais pour
oignons c'est beaucoup mieux parce que
oignons ça vient de haut niveau et
oignons c'est humain c'est à dire que
sly elle alors que l'aïe a plusieurs
booth l'oignon dans l'ain qu'une
aiguille donc c'était si une seule un
seul but le disons qu'ils que qu'on peut
et enfin comme ça qu'on peut éplucher
avec délai feuille qui s'envole et unes
après les autres mais c'est un
c'est-à-dire l'oignon il est unique si
j'ose dire je vais te revoir il est bien
plus intéressant mais pour nous la
cuisse ouvriers alors ce qui est
intéressant pour vous la nuit ce sont
les les pièges du nom il y en a beaucoup
dans votre livre des pièces juno par
exemple les marrons glacés a tout
bêtement elle pense que dans les marrons
glacés il ya des marrons et bien non
vous vous savez qu'il ya des châtaignes
voilà en fait le barreau n'est pas du
tout comme le comestibles c'est pas bon
du tout tandis que quand une châtaigne
et très grosse on l'appelle marot mais
on ne fait que la plaie marot et les
marrons glacés ne peuvent être que des
châtel des grosses châtaignes pas du
tout des barons du marronnier voilà
alors ce que j'ai derrière moi par
exemple là je pense que ce sont des
châtaignes
voilà là j'ai des châtaignes et les
barons revanche ça qu on va regardant
les marrons la seule marron et dans les
marrons glacés les châtaignes c'est pas
les marrons autres faux amis la faune ne
servait que dans les langues étrangères
on les appelle marc aux marrons glacés
en à la française dès ma peau grasse et
comme ils disent en italie alors c'est
comme quand je sais pas si vous vouliez
parler de s'armer mais il me vient
l'idée l'histoire du champignon en
français champignons ça veut dire de la
campagne en sait quelque chose
dans la campagne avec un mot d'origine
latine
mais lorsque le mot lorsque le mot est
passée dans dans en italien il est passé
sous le nom champignons shopping
champignons comme y disent les
champignons et et les champignons
ce ne sont pas des n'importe quel ce
n'est pas n'importe quel champignons qui
en italien se dit fundi fougue au
singulier fourier au pluriel mais
seulement les champignons de paris et
les anglais 19 tonnes qui vient de
mousseron c'est à une espèce de
champignon ou ce n'est sur quillan et on
voit que entre l'italien et l'élan et
l'anglais il ya eu quelque chose d'un
verse c'est à dire d'un côté on a donné
à l'espagne en france est un champignon
c'est n'importe quel champignons c'est
comme on dit comme disent les linguistes
un hyper aux dîmes c'est-à-dire un terme
générique qui avait opté recouvre tous
les champignons toutes les espèces de
champignons
quand s'est passée en italien c'est
devenu un iep onyme c'est-à-dire un
quelque chose qui est spécifique
spécifique c'est-à-dire le champignon de
paris mais pas de lesseps pas des bolets
pas par et sépare pas les métros fait de
la mort reste on verra quand au
contraire s'est passé en anglais on
n'est pas en anglais on s'est passé on
est parti d'un champignon son pignon
particulier qui est le mousseron petit
champignon enfin que tu me brand que je
suis pas très bien la taille du goût
seront donc comblés par partie de la
passe quelque chose de spécifique et
cette venue en anglais macherot m'a
choqué qui du coup générique c'est à
dire un hyper haut niveau et ça me
permet vous dire que justement c'est la
première fois dans un temps mort c'est
le premier de vélib dans lesquels je me
permet d'employer certains termes
techniques mais évidemment tout de suite
en et définissant dans des petits
encadrés qui sont identifiés grâce à un
petit tout petit club comme pour pour
montrer que c'est quelque chose d'un
petit peu particulier et la jcct
j'explique la chose et j'ai un ami qui
m'a dit
il a apprit ainsi que le mot et timon il
connaissait alors que c'est quelqu'un de
très savants et il sait tout il m'a dit
qu'il avait appris dans mon livre
justement par ces petits encadrés très
particulier disant qu'un équipement
c'est le mot est le mode latin par
exemple d'où est sorti le mot français
dont nous parlons voilà alors d'axa
autre exemple de deux pièges du nom
framboise on pourrait croire que
framboise on entend fraises et on
l'entend bois donc on se dit la
framboise et la fraise des bois
il fallait en fait c'est tout après
trois et un autre voilà et c'est tout à
fait à nos un autre fruit
d'ailleurs pour ne pas se tromper
vous savez il y à cette appellation qui
binominal qui a été donné par l'ine au
xviiie siècle par permettant de étant
donné que tout les objets tout tout tout
tout les les choses de la nature que
douter que nous avons nous les dix
n'écrivons quelquefois nous les deux
bouts de leurs deux noms des noms
différents selon la région dans laquelle
on est où selon le pays dans lequel on
est et pour ne pas se tromper pour que
les gens de ceux de sa sage bien qu'il
parle bien de telles de telles espèces
et pas d'une autre il y à cette
définition qui est donnée par l'ine et
qui est on a le bis lé binominal c'est à
dire que la première partie donne la
l'espèce elle est là la deuxième le
genre ton
voilà le genre est l'espèce donc ça
permet avec le nom servant que je donne
en général entre parenthèses pour être
bien sûr qu'on parle de la même chose je
la donne et 7 ans atteint en général
c'est ce que ce sont les noms savants
comme on appelle ça alors ça sent le
savons mais vous savez que cela t'a
bizarre justement j'ai essayé de le
décider un petit peu et j'ai répété que
ce que cdt ni d'une attaque classique ni
d'une interview hier c'était le la tasse
et le latin des natures
la liste ils ont inventé en latin en
latin a eu c'est à dire qu'ils y
prennent des bases soit latine soit
grecque
et puis il en faut des mots latins
souvent avec une terminaison us ou une
terminaison à et puis c'est tout mais
très souvent on se dit mais quel est le
mot latin d'où ça vient et on ne trouve
pas et vous savez ce que c'est comme
quand on ne trouve pas c'est le nom d'un
savant qui est un grand botaniste ou un
grand zoo le zoologue et ses acquis
qu'ils veulent au doré et philippe rey y
prennent le nom épi my mind de salles
tout à la fin uffheim ou us et puis
voilà c'est dans cette drôle en fait y'a
il ya un sabir latin comme il ya un
sabir de l'anglais ya deux il ya un
latin de cuisine
rampon comme il ya comme il ya un
franglais des affaires je sais leur
latin de cuisine moi je dirais je dirais
qu'il faut pas être méchant il faut dire
le latin des botanistes ou le latin des
voix la liste oriens de van thành enfin
on fait une petite pause et on se
retrouve juste après on continue avec
d'autres mots de la cuisine et de la
table
[Musique]
la linguiste oria de valter vient de
publier les petits plats dans les grands
aux éditions robert laffont ce qui est
l'occasion de faire un un tour des mots
et de leur histoire les mots de la table
et de la cuisine j'ai appris en lisant
votre livre henriette que au moyen-âge
les fruits et les légumes
c'était de la viande en fait on appelait
ça la viande végétales les céréales
c'était la viande farineuse le viandier
c'était le cuisinier il y avait la
viande rouge comme aujourd'hui avec la
viande blanche comme aujourd'hui il y
avait aussi la viande noir c'était le
jour avant tout été de la viande
voilà exactement mais bien sûr alors est
ce qu il faut savoir bien sûr on route
on retrouve là le verbe vivere latin qui
se veut dire vivre bien sûr donc c'est
ce qui aide à vivre
donc c'est n'importe quelle nourriture
au fond c'était c'est pourquoi on avait
des possibilités de dire la blanche la
rougeole est là j'allais dire la verve
mais non il n'y a pas de viande ouverte
mais bon donc ça permettait de
distinguer les choses voilà est donc
tout à l'heure tout à l'heure nous
parlions de l'assiette qui n'existe pas
et c'est exactement c'est également
quelque chose qui qui est payé à la
soupe aussi la soupe qui a changé de
sens ce week-end c'était la soupe au
moyen âge alors la société or ce pas
finalement c'était pour ça qu'il y a qu
il ya 7 l/100 morse pas que l'on d'un
bib est avec du du potage avec don avec
du bouillon parce que potage ça sens un
petit peu plus particulier donc donc
c'était c'était ce que l'on sait c'est
est le pain qu'on habille bay c'est
pourquoi on dit trempé comme une soupe
vous voyez quand on dit qu'on est trempé
comme une soupe c'est à dire comme un
morceau de pain qui est trompé grâce au
bouillon il ya des choses qui ont changé
de nom c'était amusant
la pomme de terre qui est certainement
aujourd'hui le légume le plus utilisé
et par les français quand ils font la
cuisine ça c'est alors la pomme de terre
ou la connais elle est derrière moi tout
le monde reconnaît une pomme de terre
est bien au moyen-âge ils ont rappelé à
une truffe exacte appelée certains trucs
tartuffe aussi tardé boudou la
tartiflette ou tard des fleuves en
savoie par exemple on disait nat article
est donc la tartiflette n'a rien à voir
avec avec une tarte
si je veux dire c'est fade que font les
iraniens on croit que c'est avec des
truffes non sitebay la pomme de terre
c'est autrement dit l'élément le plus le
plus luxueux qui est là un truc qui est
le plus cher est le nom qui est le même
que pour l'élément qui est le moins cher
quand on n'a pas de beaucoup d'argent on
mange des pommes de terre des patates
voilà on a là un autre dimension un
autre mot qui nous étaient qui dit
qu'ils nous aiment unis est venue
d'amérique que d'ailleurs la pomme de
terre nous est arrivé avec difficulté
mais elle a fait beaucoup de bien
et bien sûr vous ça vous connaissez
l'histoire de parmentier parmentier qui
qui a voulu faire faire accepter aux
français de manger des pommes de terre
mais à cette époque là quand c'est
arrivé
les gens pensaient que c'était dangereux
et que c'était un poison donc un
parmentier s'est milliard à faire ce
qu'il pouvait pour que tout le monde
puisse manger et parmentier a été libre
et imité par quelqu'un d'autre quelqu'un
que vous connaissez bien que tout le
monde connaît depuis qu'il y à
l'électricité qui est volta alessandro
vol d'un vol dans celui qui est
l'inventeur de la pile électrique qui en
italie a fait exactement la même chose
que parmentier france il d'aller voir
les paysans car il y avait une pénurie
de blé et il leur a dit écoutez dans
votre ventre à votre nourriture
essayez donc cette chose-là qui n'est
pas cher équivalent vous nous
rires et si on se donnait les gnocchis
les yeux et la peau et lui il a il a
demandé que l'on mette dans la dans la
semoule disons au début les gnocchis
n'était que de semoule et maintenance et
il y en a aussi à la pomme de terre est
d'ailleurs en italie on distinct d'entre
eux ignorent qui dit pas ça tu es idiot
qui disent alors du temps où les pommes
de terre qui sont derrière moi on
appelait ça des truffes
je rappelle que ce sont les truffes
d'aujourd'hui on va les voir ça c'est
aujourd'hui ce sont des truffes voilà
c'est assez des truffes
mais à l'époque on appelait les pommes
de terre des truffes
qu'est-ce qu'ils étaient les pommes de
terre et bien en lisant votre livre j'ai
appris que c'était les topinambours
c'est à dire les topinambours qu'on va
voir apparaître
on appelait ça des pommes de terre et
donc et donc les pommes de terre
c'était la pomme de terre colloque que
l'on va appeler le tourisme c'est tout
cela que l'on a appelé plutôt pied
gauche et le topinambour
c'est un légume qui a été oublié vous
servez pourquoi vous êtes trop jeune
pour le savoir mais en fait pendant la
guerre il y avait que des topinambours
ou des rutabagas et ce sont deux les que
les gens ensuite non plus j'avais voulu
manger le temps où on s'est dit que
finalement il faut essayer de regoûter
le topinambour mais je sais pas si vous
l'avez si vous rangez de temps en temps
des tons pedro messi délicieux ça a un
petit goût d'artichaut très très très
très très délicat et il faut absolument
oublier maintenant il n'y a plus la
génération qui a connu la guerre et
presque j'en fais partie mais bon y'en a
plus beaucoup comme moi voilà les deux
fois il y en a plus beaucoup
donc voilà il faut oublier la guerre et
manger et moi je vous conseille de
manger du topinambour
c'est très bon vous avez prononcé le mot
artichauts quand vous prononcez de marty
show forcément je pense à catherine de
médicis qui était la femme d'henry d'eux
qu'ils étaient
de france mais ensuite régente puisque
ses trois fils ont régné successivement
et elle a eu un poids politique
considérable en france
on lui attribue d'ailleurs le massacre
de la saint-barthélemy les historiens en
discute mais en revanche elle nous a
apporté plein d'autres choses catherine
de médicis dont les artichauts
voilà un land en dans les livres de
cuisine elle est bel et bien vu si je
vous lire les fonds en euros
elle est bien vue on ne pense pas aux
massacres avec elle parfait en fait elle
était très gourmande
il ya l'artichaut comme vous dites il y
aller les épinards
il y aller o les flageolets il y à aussi
on pense aussi à la crème de la crème
vous avez été comme fouettés c'est ça la
crème fouettée qui est qui est au fond à
l'origine de la crème chantilly dit
chantilly donc la crème fouettée
c'est ces petits catherine de médicis
qui qui la font et ils y aller tout à
l'heure j'ai dit les pédales je sais pas
si je les dis mais les épinards c'est
intéressant parce que maintenant quand
on dit je voudrais des escalopes alarme
chloroquine c'est quoi des escalopes à
la florentine
et bien c'est des escalopes avait des
épis d'or est à portée de de florence
qui était là la patrie si je le vire de
catherine de médicis qui a été derrière
florence et et la frangipane qu'on met
dans la galette des rois c'est aussi un
catherine de médicis qu'on le doit
et c'est à dire ça en france voilà alors
on dit que on ne sait pas très bien ce
nom faire un petit panneau c'est un
c'est le nom de quelqu'un on dit enfin
on a un petit doute parce qu'il ya 2,2
frangipane il y en a deux de l'époque de
catherine de médicis on pense que c'est
un cadeau qu'il doit il y aurait fait au
moment de son mariage mais il y a comme
il ya un autre frenchy paniqué deux
siècles plus tard on ne sait pas si
c'est celui ci ou celui là qui a laissé
son nom reprend donc voilà vélo coupal
rose s'est fait à base d'amandes et ses
essais la galette des rois pour noah
alors quand on lit les grands oui pardon
j'ai pas compris non je dis quand on lit
les grands romans du xixème siècle
alexandre dumas balzac flaubert
on est toujours embêté et que bout
d'idées quand il parle de dîner on
comprend que c'est pas d'idées auquel on
pense nous et et j'ai trouvé la réponse
dans votre livre jusqu'au 19ème siècle
mais ça dépend des régions
le dîner c'était le déjeuner mais vous
savez que encore maintenant lorsque vous
avez dans certaines régions si on vous
dit qu'on vous invite à dîner il faudra
il faut tout de suite demandé mais à
quelle heure vous voulez vous parce que
il faut parce que son petit d'avoir un
doute ça peut être lui peut penser que
c'est le repas de midi et vous pensez
que c'est leur part le repas du soir
si vous allez au canada au québec ou
dans les régions acadiennes
c'est la même chose le dîner pour eux
c'est c k bidy c'est pas le soir une
soir c'est le souper mais porno ou le
souper c'est plus loin c'est plus tard
de nous avons le petit déjeuner le
déjeuner le dîner et le souper le soupe
elle viendrait après le spectacle alors
vous me direz qu aujourd'hui le
spectacle il y en a plus tellement on
n'a plus le droit d'y aller bon il ya
plus de soupe et lesparre voilà j'aime
penser d'ailleurs que c'est la première
émission je fais depuis longtemps on n'a
pas encore parlé du cornât virus celle
où on n'en parlera pas parce que ça n'a
pas de rapport avec votre livre n'est
fait parler d'eux après spectacle ça
fait plaisir parce qu'on se dit que ça
va bientôt revenir pendant des siècles
dites-vous en rien valter le pas en
france étaient en forme de boule le 1
c'était ça c'était un pain voilà et d'où
la loupe boulanger en fait parce que
j'ai les boules
et voilà c'était c'était des boules je
me souviens que il ya quelques jours
quelqu'un qui est qui était pas eu d une
jeune fille qui était polonaise 10e mais
il n'y a pas souvent des mange plutôt
des baguettes que que déboule emprunt
que des miches de pain ronde et jeudi et
à ce moment je lui ai expliqué jeudi b
et vous savez que autre forme il y avait
que ça il y avait que ça
et là bas gagnent c'est quelque chose
d'assez récent c'est le début du 20e
siècle était vous savez que la baguette
elle est née à paris et pas ailleurs
en 1930 et il s'en était sympa c'est un
pas un peu idiot quand on y pense
puisque c'est un pas qui ne se conserve
pas c'est un pain qui dure trois heures
une baguette et on la préférait la
baguette à toutes ces boules qu'on
pouvait conserver très très bien très
facilement puisqu'elle elles restent
elles restent bonnes pendant parfois des
jours
tant qu'on ne les tranches pas
évidemment mais comme les boulangers
aujourd'hui en plus veule voulait
trancher c'est pour vous faire revenir
plus vite et voix je me souviens le hot
d'or quand je suis arrivé un pari on
allait acheter la baguette le matin puis
une autre bague est le soir un bon
qu'elle soit fraîche vraiment fera
maintenant c'est fini on ne fait plus
des choses pareilles
mais mais mais celle ça a été le cas
avec certains l'ont refait récemment
pendant le confinement parce que c'était
comme ça l'occasion de sortir deux fois
dans la journée on va les jeter et
d'ailleurs certaines municipalités ont
interdit qu'on achète moins d'une mois
deux baguettes trop prompt pour eux
et alors ce qui est intéressant c'est
que la baguette est devenu un peu est
apparue d'un succès international
quand d'abord c'est devenu presque
symbolique de français quand on veut
représenter en français qu'est ce qu'on
fait en lui mais la baguette à la main
et on lui met une brune une paire basse
alors le béret basque je ne vois pas
très bien pourquoi mais la balle à
paillettes oui et alors
quand j'étais jeune j'ai eu l'occasion
d'aller faire des conférences en
nouvelle zélande et j'étais hors
nouvelle zélande 14 juillet et j'ai été
invité dans un restaurant où pour une
fois il n'y avait que des baguettes 2 et
baguettes sur la table et donc non pas
l'heure pas qu'ils ont d'habitude qui
était remis un peu alors il s vous voyez
voilà alors il a évidemment il ya tout
un chapitre sur les appellations
géographiques puisque la cuisine
évidemment
il ya très souvent recours et on
s'aperçoit par exemple que l'ex qu'on
appelle la fondue bourguignonne
c'est-à-dire de l'eau bouillante dans
lequel on va plonger de la viande mais
la fondue bourguignonne n'est absolument
pas bourguignonne et n'aurait pas du
tout pas du tout c'est simplement la la
la la la fondue savoyarde qui est faite
avec du fromage qui a été modifié à un
certain moment on s'est dit et pourquoi
est ce qu on ne ferait pas ça avec du
boeuf charolais boeufs charolais boeuf
bourguignon d'ouvriers et et la tarte
tropézienne
alors là la tarte tropézienne qu'on va
voir derrière moi voilà ça c'est une
tarte tropézienne et alors qu'elle est
quelle est son histoire elle est faite
avec une nuée une patte de brioches la
patte de brioches elle-même était a été
inventé en pologne
alors oui parce qu'en fait tout à
l'heure nous avons parlé de catherine de
médicis
mais peut-être faut-il dire un mot de
stanislas excusez moi je vais prononcer
le mot à l'heure française mais il sait
comme ça parce qu'on se comprend en
france l'exode qui vous savez bien qu'en
polonais se prononcent pas comme ça bon
style exane ce pays qui était un grand
grand gourmand et qui avait demandé un
saut à son pâtissier de faire une pâte
de une pâte qui est devenue la patte du
kougelhopf et la dent dans l'atteinte
aux tropézienne il y à cette même carte
cette même patte disons et ce coup gland
je reviens un petit peu au golf
le public sait dont une une brioche un
petit peu particulière que nous avons
appelé plus tard le baba et c'est le ba
ba qui a été inventé par le cuisinier de
l'est de stanislas et l'exercice key qui
a dit mais pourquoi de mettriez vous
parle sur cette pâte de google offre qui
est un petit peu sèche qui était pieds
va un peu de d'un 20 20 un vin sucré
vous voyez quelque chose comme ça
aujourd'hui on dit le baba au rhum
mais à l'époque ce n'était pas ivre
baroque setubal à durban
un peu un peu imbibés ils ont cessé
cette même patte qui est dans la tarte
tropézienne voiliers et c'était 1 et
caen si vous allez à saint tropez on
vous dit la meilleure tarte tropézienne
elle est chez mica mika est leur mika
s'est éteint ma pâtissier qui était
d'origine polonaise et qui a eu la bonne
idée de faire de prendre cette patte du
kougelhopf inquiets et une brioche
disons tout simple et d'y mettre une
crème extraordinaire très très raffinée
et très est très très fine et ça a eu
beaucoup de succès mais pourquoi ben
c'est grâce à brigitte bardot comme tout
à sa trempe et oui au parent on part de
sa distance qui ont travers ce don fait
un voyage on va ça trop peu et on va
chez brigitte bardot mais pourquoi parce
qu'ils étaient ceux qui saignait qui
s'appelait mika jeudi bika à la
française bien sûr bmi cck 1 il était
donc le pilier il avait il avait pour
mission de de nourrir is hot toute
l'équipe qui était en train de tourner
un film avec brigitte bardot a brisé la
à la femme
voilà exactement et c'est là que que la
tarte tropézienne est devenu et on l'a
appelée tarte tropézienne mais elle n'a
rien de tropéziens
voilà alors il est l épaule au dance et
et si on fait vraiment d'histoire elle
et stanislas lipinski et et la
bouillabaisse
alors c'est nous tout à courre lisant
votre livre j'ai réalisé mais oui c'est
vrai dans bouillabaisse il ya bouillir
et ya baissé et c'est le il faut baisser
le feu dès que ça commence à bouillir
aux baisses le feu parce que les poinsot
il faut il faut les soigner
il faut qu'il soit avec une température
pas trop élevé pour qu'ils ne cèdent les
fasse pas n'est ce pas voilà donc c'est
bien et ça me fait penser
bien sûr la ratatouille puisque nous
sommes dans le midi il y à la
ratatouille
mais vous savez que bon la ratatouille
ses pouvoirs a atteint tôt il sait quoi
céder
avoir des tomates on y mettait peut-être
des courgettes de l'oignon de l'ail de
l'huile d'olive et enfin des trucs comme
ça mais bon mais ça c'est quelque chose
qui se retrouve partout en méditerranée
latta la ratatouille c'est aussi la
caponata ah oui mais attention la
capitale c'est la même chose mais il
faut y ajouter des câpres et la
farrapona ça se trouve seulement
l'italie et puis il y à là la
chakhchoukha chakchouka dans dans les
pays d'afrique du nord tunisie algérie
maroc en tunisie
je connais bien la chakhchoukha puisque
je suis né en tunisie
donc la chakhchoukha ce sont les mêmes
ingrédients mais ils sont cuits sur le
feu sur avec de l'huile d'olive sur sur
le feu
simplement sur le feu maintenant il ya
aussi d'un méchoui ya alors des fuyards
c'est les mêmes ingrédients c'est à dire
poivrons tomates ail huile d'olive les
vainqueurs mais ils sont pillés par an
en arabe mais je fuyais ça veut dire ce
qui est grillé comme le méchoui voyez le
méchoui c'est la même origine qu'eux que
méchouia donc vous voyez qu'on a tout ça
et pia revient aussi alors dans le midi
de la france
il y a le tian té i am le tian mais
c'est les mêmes c'est les mêmes
ingrédients
c'est la même chose mais le temps est
beaucoup plus jolie
vous savez pourquoi c'est lorsque c'est
s'est installé dans un plat un plat qui
vend four qui est un plat en terre qui
va au four et où ce sont de belles
petites rangées petites rangées de de
courgettes au titre au rejet de touba
touati tranchée de poivrots petit ange
et d'aubergines et puis on recommence on
recommence et finalement rôle mais dans
le fou et c'est très joli quand on le
sait donc c'est encore mieux c'est
encore mieux mais tout ça si la même
chose si j'ose dire ce sont les 21
regret dian mais qui sont préparés ou
autrement
selon la région où on est et seulement
selon le goût des gens parce
qu'aujourd'hui on air on aime bien la
cuisine un petit peu mélangés c'est à
dire que on mélange la cuisine la
cuisine vietnamienne avec la cuisine je
sais pas espagnole ou chilienne 1
la fusée certainement le style du 21e
que ce soit en musique en en cuisine
dans tous les domaines c'est la fusion
et on aime ça mais on aime aussi savoir
comment c'était commencé pour les ceux
qui sont les plus les plus strictes
disons où on vous dit je pense tout d'un
coup à la salade niçoise cdc c'est pas
du tout étranger
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
très connu vous savez que quand on parle
avec des spécialistes salade niçoise ils
vous disent surtout jamais de deux
mètres je ne jamais mettre de légumes
cuits c'est à dire pas de haricots verts
pas de pommes de terre dans la salade
niçoise mais forcément il y a du temps
forcément il ya des olives noires
forcément il y à du basilic voyez il ya
des choses dans lesquelles les gens sont
ils des pas question de discuter
prenez la quiche lorraine la quiche
lorraine il ya des gens qui vous diront
pas trop et je vais je mets du fromage
dont il n'est pas question donc je sais
pas si vous mettez du probable il ya des
gens qui il n'est pas question de vendre
du fromage landes à l'origine n'y avait
pas de fromage effectivement mais alors
il y avait un exemple qui est amusant
dans votre livre c'est celui des
champignons de paris
les championnes paris vous le disiez
d'ailleurs au départ c'est un terme
spécifique qui est devenu un terme
générique et et les champignons de paris
qu'on voit derrière moi mais aujourd'hui
ils sont plus paris il dit non plus il
descend plus de paris depuis que depuis
qu'on a fabriqué le métro puisque la
place oui c'est le métro qui a call qui
a chassé le champignon et qui maintenant
le champignon de paris était tout à fait
ailleurs voilà alors c'est vrai qu'on
leur rend le cultivaient sous la terre
et maintenant c'est en anjou qu'on a
depuis qu'elle métro à paris on a
transporté le champion de paris en anjou
et la choucroute alors étymologiquement
la choucroute
c'est une vraie découverte en fait le
clown mais pas dans le chou il est dans
la croûte
c'est à dire que c'est un mot d'origine
germanique qui forme et sûr sûr sûr moi
fier biseau ou évidemment ses craintes
quant aux normes allemandes qui est là
fouquet lapar donkey et le chou voilà
alors que péter le moche ou le mot
chaude en choucroute signifie aigre
voilà ça vous savez c'est la même racine
que ça en anglais
quand on dit ça est ce un voilà voilà le
mot alsacien c'est sûr croûte est sûre
ça veut dire ingres et crouttes ça veut
dire chou est le suivant question c'est
ça en anglais tu peux tu veu diret gotti
voilà le bacon c'est un bon club école
alors non justement c'est un mot
français qui est passé en anglais comme
vous savez le vocabulaire anglais est à
70% du vocabulaire d'origine française
mais il nous est revenu c'est à dire que
il est parti en angleterre sous la forme
bacon c'était le bateau qui était de
viande de porc que vous traversez et
puis s'il nous est revenue mais
maintenant quand on a quand on achète du
bacon à la halle à un chapitre i ce
n'est pas du tout ce n'est pas du tout
ce que nous dispensons c'est à dire que
le bacon de la le bacon que nous
achetons c'est du lard maigre alors que
le bacon qui est parti en angleterre aux
11e 12e siècle c'était du gras c'est à
dire celui qui fait les lardons oublier
les c'est pas le même le le ketchup
d'ailleurs qu'au couru le ketchup vous
dites qu'on le connaissait des gens en
france à la fin du 19e siècle
le ketchup et d'ailleurs que c'est même
pas un mot anglais ketchup samo chinois
un coup dit et chinois
ces chinois est brossé on pense que ces
américains
mais en fait non c'est ces chinois on
doit un rôdeur beaucoup chinois
finalement dans la cuisine il ya il ya
pas mal de choses qui ne sont arrivés de
chine énormément même dernières
découvertes c
le célèbre peintre du xviie siècle
claude le lorrain à peintre
aujourd'hui voilà il était capable de
faire un tableau comme celui ci est
d'une valeur inestimable
mais c'est aussi qu'on ne leur en
inventant de la pâte feuilletée
exactement c'est à dire qu'ils étaient
ils à il a été avant d'être connue avant
d'être tendre il a été apprenti
boulanger et un jour on lui a demandé de
faire une une pâte
disons une patte n'importe qui n'importe
laquelle il a oublié de mettre le beurre
quand il s'est souvenu qu'il fallait
mettre le vin il se dit que c'est déjà
fait la page est déjà tournée
je vais mettre le beurre par dessus et
puis je vais faire court je les
recouvrir la pac et c'est ainsi qu'est
né quand il ay la fécule et il a prouvé
que c'était pas mal ils sont pas trop on
a beaucoup félicité et eu même type
d'erreur qui avait donné la bêtise de
cambrai en fait c'est pour ça qu'on
l'appelle à bêtises de cambrai parce que
c'était une bêtise de pas voilà c'est
une erreur et c'est la même chose avec
le pineau des charentes 1 7 euro ont dit
c'est une erreur qui a été peinte par
quelqu'un qui a rajouté du du cognac
disons sur un fût quelqu'un decker le
pardon qui a qu'à rajouter du vin sur
eux qui avaient déjà un petit reste de
cognac et depuis quand
merci à henriette valter d'avoir passé
toute cette émission avec nous les
petits plats dans les grands il ya
encore des centaines d'anecdotes qu'on a
pas évoqué dans cette émission
c'est le livre vient de sortir aux
éditions robert laffont merci henriette
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]